the Joe Rogan experience well you can
learn the fundamentals the right way to
hit a ball learning how to do things
with a ball bearing Hannah move the ball
correctly leg shot like this most people
have no idea where well I'm gonna catch
one from there to the four ball so I
want to get on here so you have to hit
the 4 ball the four balls next oh shit
after three after three I got to get
into position for the floor so I hit it
flat so it slides out I owe geometry
it's all about you don't want to be over
here you want to be able to hear because
the natural progression is here to slide
down here for this ball so when I hit
this ball and now wave it on you're
gonna hit that paint ball into that
pocket yes
so now I'm not thinking about that
that's easy
what's important is getting in a good
position for this ball and just speaking
you've got to hit that ball there right
there around there right why I have to
hit it exactly right here because that's
the only way you're gonna make it if you
draw a line to where the ball where well
there's a lot of it's instinctive
because I understand where the contact
point is and I'm gonna hit it with
which was left hand English wanna spin
okay yeah what the fuck is that see how
the Sharks like to perform I'll post
right now what you're gonna do now I'm
gonna pocket that again this is really
awesome this yep talk about in that
corner that that's that feels like it's
no that goes right by but the most
important thing is getting out here it's
about getting out here for the side
pocket because this is what's important
but not just here the down we can't be
up table because then you got to do all
this you want to hit that white ball you
want to get a position where where do
you want a second ball so I want to make
sure that I have an angle in the seven
ball so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
hit it low and just slide nauseous so
now from here this is pretty easy
my only concern is I don't get stuck
behind the 10th off I get stuck behind
the 10 ball then I don't have a shot at
the 8th so I want to play towards the
danger zone which is like this side rail
so I don't want to I don't want to
scratch but I don't like it stuck behind
the 10th
see how close I am myself I can't see it
I was worried about that I really wanted
to land like right here perfect but see
like that kind of position that takes
fucking years to learn how to do to
learn how how hard you're supposed to be
hitting the ball to make it react like
that if you don't have that kind of
pinpoint precision the ability to so
frozen one like to tales of conversation
to the best guys can build ten tenten
yeah especially in practice when there's
no money on the line there's just
nothing there just having a good time
and they can run fucking terrorizing
crazy shit I've run for broken run for
rocks in the run of nine ball which is
way harder than a blow well night no
nine ball is is a rotation then eight
ball you have a bunch of different
choices you can choose to shoot you know
any color or a solid or any strike
rather a solid but whereas in nine ball
you're playing the rotation so every
shot there's no options no no your nine
ball is you're shooting the balls one
through nine one two three four five six
seven eight nine you get the nine you
win whereas with eight ball you're
either solids or stripes you get a lot
more options you can take your shots
still it doesn't even fit two balls in
out this is a very very tight table so
this is a protein much more it's more
tighten up rotatable
practice time yeah well it's like a
table for people that you know any
bullshit you don't want to waltz up
bobble in you know if you look amazing
you didn't pick up golf you would have
never scare us careful that's not too
many people so I'm too many people just
picked us golf and then became fucking
nuts
yeah they would just play all day and it
takes too much you got damn time
yeah like you could go play pool for an
hour you can't play golf for an hour
playing golf you're playing all day yeah
it's like that shit so we'll do the top
pool guy make it that is a problem
dog shit right even though the number
one
no one got in the world like make a
quarter bunny bucks and there's not that
much those guys travel that they lost
whatever like remaining respect I happen
and I lost when they published this
[Music]
justification for drones are working
they than other forms of warfare and it
read like a PR piece is like to paint
like which defense contractor paid for
this bullshit because it's just totally
demented what's the source of the
motivation to do a story you know after
you hear about amber Lyons experience of
seeing how much singing on television
and reading in the newspaper is filtered
through propaganda probably quite a bit
yeah I was watching part of the Kimmel
last night yeah Johnny Depp on so think
about how that format is just that's
what most people are consuming and it's
so weird if you have somebody there for
five or six minutes they don't share
anything that's important like you never
see even though I think it was the best
way by those I do too you never see like
so funny what's the meaning of life like
what I try to do it
it's like meaningless bullshit that I've
already forgotten Brian he flies back to
South France or wherever he's from
that's it like yeah that's to promote
his new movie and you don't learn
anything more about what he believes
about the world or politics that's a
good points like the whole format was
created before the much better format
that we have now yeah and then the whole
commercials we'll be right back where
are you going you got on right there
fucking talk to him like everyone knows
a conversation sort of ramps up like you
know conversate you sit down and then
you get loose and after a while then you
start really it has a flow to it and
that flow is completely interrupted if
you start doing a commercial every 7
minutes
whatever it is we'll go with that format
Kimmel does a great job because you can
tell me he's really smart really that's
the feeling I get maybe that's just his
personality but it's like you can go a
lot further you can push things further
you don't have to and you don't mean
it's the fucking Tonight Show I mean I
know he's not Jay Leno but it's still
it's a nice show yeah the people
watching it now we have no problem
watching it on YouTube the next day yeah
but doing all these things for this
hypothetical old lady in the Midwest I
think you're right in some ways but the
bottom line is there are revenues
directly related to their the ratings
and so thinking that OH most people
going to watch on YouTube that doesn't
translate financially yeah still that's
the main motivation is still fine
Automation they don't look they look at
those numbers were fuck will calm they
they have fuckin detailed by the minute
analysis breakdown when Kimmel started
talking about tomatoes people don't care
about Tomatoes don't talk about Tomatoes
yeah look we dropped off 1% you know
when you turn you know they they have
that they have like these number bean
counter dudes to really concerned about
they do yeah well even some of the big
YouTube channels and friends with the
guy the video doesn't do as well as they
expected and that rarely happens because
they know so well and their audience
wants at this point what kind of videos
do they make we do like news
entertainment
two minute long clips but two minute
long toes
[Music]